The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Most likely this
will be a two-hour lecture
with a short break, so I
am teaching until 3 o'clock
and we have of the
classroom until 3 o'clock.
Let's jump right
into cold fermions.
Almost everything
I say in this talk
is some advice in a review paper
which Professor [? Swiller ?]
and myself wrote
a few years ago.
The paper will be posted
to the group website
later this afternoon.
OK, when we cool down fermions,
Lithium-6 and Boson sodiums
we immediately
notice a difference.
The sodium cloud shrink,
shrink, shrinks and forms
a small Bose-Einstein
condensate,
whereas the lithium
cloud stops to shrink
when we reach the
degeneracy temperature.
And, of course, you know
it's at low temperature.
At high temperature the gases
have very similar behavior,
but at low temperature they
look very, very different.
And that can be
directly observed.
We know that bosons do something
very special at low temperature
and we talked a lot
about it in this course.
Namely, they become
superfluid and form
a Bose-Einstein
condensate, whereas,
for single-component
fermions, there
is some interesting physics
in form of Fermi sea,
but nothing really special.
So, in order to do something
more interesting with fermions
you need two kinds of fermions.
And two kinds of
fermions can form pairs.
To think, for a moment, two
atoms can form a molecule
and those Bosonic
pairs can condense
into Bose-Einstein condensate
and becomes superfluid again.
If that would be all to
Fermionic superfluidity
I would be almost done
right now and would say,
"OK a Bosonic atom is
a composite particle
made of nuclei and
nucleus and electrons.
Well, a bosonic molecule
is a composite particle,
but in the end they
do both the same."
But the special
things about fermions
is there is another form of
pairing, which is much, much,
weaker.
And this is the form which
leads to superconductivity
of electrons.
It's Cooper pairing.
And this is really
much more subtle
because the pairs
are much larger
than the inter-particle
separation.
Now, in atomic physics,
we have a wonderful tool
to study pairing because
atoms can form molecules,
weakly bound molecules or
tightly bound molecules.
And we can control
that in experiments
with the Feshbach resonance.
Assume you have two
atoms, which collide,
and they can form a molecule.
And if you apply
a magnetic field
the two free atoms
and the molecule
may have a different
Zeeman shift,
and therefore, there
may be a level crossing.
And this is called, as a
function of magnetic field,
the Feshbach resonance.
If the crossing isn't
crossing nothing
happens because the two
configurations would not
interact.
So, physics happens when
there are interactions
for some hyperfine
coupling, for instance,
which takes the crossing
into an anti-crossing.
And now you see the
following physics
around this Feshbach resonance,
that we have two atoms here.
Here, we have a stable molecule.
And there are many, many more
molecular states down there,
but for this restricted Hilbert
space this is the lowest state.
It's a stable molecule.
The atoms, if you compare the
solid line with a dashed line,
attract each other because the
solid line has lower energy,
whereas, on the other side
of the Feshbach resonance
they repel each other.
So therefore, if you
look at the scattering
lengths of the normalized
force between atoms
we find this disparity feature
around the Feshbach resonance,
and atomic physics
wouldn't be the same
without Feshbach resonances.
We can now tune attractive
repulsive interactions.
In a richer situation
there may also
be Zero-crossings of the
scattering lengths, which
allows us to realize
non-interacting systems
and such.
And Feshbach
resonances were first
observed at MIT
some 15 years ago.
So coming back to fermions.
This Feshbach resonance gives
us something very interesting
regarding to pairing.
On that side where we
have stable molecules,
those molecules are
bosons and those bosons
form a Bose-Einstein
condensate of bound pairs.
Over here, we have attraction.
But the attraction is not strong
enough to form a bound state,
at least two atoms
in vacuum would not
find form a molecular state.
The attraction is too weak.
But we know from condensed
matter physics textbook
if you have many fermions,
if you have a Fermi sea,
then the Fermi sea
plus attraction
equals BCS Cooper pairs.
So now we have an opportunity,
by simply changing
the magnetic field, to go from
real, strongly-bound pairs
to weakly-bound pairs, and
eventually to Cooper pairs,
which would not form
pairs in vacuum.
And this is a kind
of physics, which
was for the first time
explored with ultra cold atoms,
in the BEC-BCS crossover.
Jenny.
AUDIENCE:Just to clarify.
So in the repulsive regime, you
said the atoms form molecules,
but the atoms repel each other.
So you're saying atoms that
don't form molecules repel each
other or [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Actually if I go back to that,
here they form molecules,
here they repel each other.
And actually a lot
of people think,
the repulsive side of
the Feshbach resonance
means there is repulsion.
But look, the atoms
attract each other
so much that they
form a molecule.
You can actually see the
repulsion of the atoms
comes because there is a very
attractive molecular state
below, and those two
states repel each other.
So the repulsion
up here is actually
caused by the molecular
state down there.
So in other words,
if you go from
the attractive to
the repulsive side--
many people use it, in terms
of pairs-- you go actually
from very weak
attraction, which is not
sufficient to form
the bound state,
to stronger and
stronger attraction,
which now forms a stronger, and
more strongly bound molecule.
Mark.
AUDIENCE: Are there ways you can
tell whether the molecules are
repulsive, or attractive just
by physics, or [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You mean what the
force is between the molecules
now?
It turns out that the
molecules are repulsive.
In some picture here,
when the molecule forms,
you can see it's a
loosely bound molecule.
And the repulsion
between atoms turns
into repulsion of molecules.
If you use an [INAUDIBLE]
which has approximations,
you would actually find
that the scattering lengths
for molecules is
exactly two times
the scattering length for atoms.
But if you work
it out correctly,
the factor is different than 2.
Colin.
AUDIENCE: You said that
the molecules are boson.
I guess they're only bosons
if the size of the molecule--
PROFESSOR: I come to that later.
We come to that later, yes.
AUDIENCE: My question was, I
guess the size of the molecule
scales pretty strongly with how
far away you from resonance,
C6 R6 balance for---
PROFESSOR: In the
universal regime, which
is open channel dominated--
sorry for talking shop--
in that regime, the
size of the molecule
is equal to one-half of
the scattering lengths.
So as the scattering
lengths diverges,
the molecule is very, very big.
And as we move
away, the molecule
gets smaller and smaller.
But once we get out of
this quadratic regime,
out of the universe of the
halo regime, then, of course,
the molecular size is
completely determined
by the close channel.
And it is whatever it
is in the close channel.
And there's no relation
to the scattering lengths.
OK.
So in other words,
it is now possible
using Feshbach resonances-- Yes.
I'm just missing colors,
those dots should be red.
Do you have a color problem.
The red has turned into black.
At least on the monitor.
That is much nicer.
On the internal
monitor it's red,
it's just that the
computer does not show red.
Let me just try that.
No, it's not cooperative.
Just one more second.
I have many more
slides with color,
so I just want to make sure
that you recognize the features.
I don't see any easy fix.
So maybe we should
live with just
imagining some of
the black is red.
So in other words, by
using a magnetic field,
we can go from
strongly-bound pairs, which
form a Bose-Einsten condensate,
to weakly-bound pairs, which
resemble Cooper pairs of
electrons in superconductors.
So this is the physics
of the BEC-BCS crossover,
and in the middle of it we find
a new form of superfluidity,
which has not really
been realized before.
Namely, you can see
these are molecules
which are too big be
to be called molecules.
Or these Cooper
pairs, which are too
small to be called Cooper pairs.
It's really pairs which
sort of elbow each other.
They just fill all the space.
The pairs are exactly as large
as the spacing between atoms.
OK.
In class I always try to teach
you something conceptional.
And the conceptional part
I want to address now
is, let's assume we are
on the right-hand side,
on the attractive side of
the Feshbach resonance.
Two atoms weakly
attract each other
with their negative
scattering lengths,
but there is no bound
molecular state.
So how should you now understand
that if you have many fermions,
that those fermions form
Cooper pairs in pairs?
And the question I
would have for you,
is-- definitely probably
heard about it--
is this paring mechanism,
which requires the Fermi
sea Is that many-body pairing?
That somehow correlation between
many particles are necessary,
and it's a genuine
many body effect?
Or can you still
understand Cooper
pairing as mainly
a two-body effect?
So in other words,
how much many-body
is really involved
in creating pairs
in the presence of a Fermi sea?
Does anybody know the answer?
What you hear from
most people is
that it's a real
many-body effect.
Two particles cannot found
form a pair in vacuum.
So it really many-body physics,
and you say "Wow, I really
have to understand
complicated physics."
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
PROFESSOR: It has something
to do with a Fermi sea.
What-- [? Timor ?] first.
AUDIENCE: I may know the answer.
Maybe you would like to--
PROFESSOR: Take it away.
AUDIENCE: There's
always a bound state
in two dimensions, I think,
between both [INAUDIBLE]
the Fermi sea helps you
get the two dimensions.
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
So what I want to show you is
exactly what [? Timor ?] said.
You can really
understand Cooper pairs.
You can understand the
exponential dependence
on the scattering
lengths by simply
looking at one particle,
at two particles,
with a very weak potential.
But you have to look
at it in two dimension.
And it is eventually
the Fermi sea
which provides a two-dimensional
density of states.
So in other words,
the binding of Cooper
pairs, at least
qualitatively, can
be understood with a
single particle Schrodinger
equation with undergraduate
physics knowledge.
Colin
AUDIENCE: I guess
the picture that
was sort of when
you think of PCS
and a real solid, like a
three dimensional solid,
is that one electron
traveling through the lattice
repels all the electrons
of similar spins
[INAUDIBLE] exclusion.
And then the electron
of another spin
moving with opposite
momentum, sort of,
sees that as a
deficit of that spin
and sort of attracted
to that region.
So in that sense isn't, sort
of this effective clearing out
of other particles to make room
for [INAUDIBLE] many bodies
associated with
Fermi sea [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Very good.
So we are talking about
two different things here.
One is we need an attraction.
In the atomic system
we get an attraction
because of van der Waal's
molecular forces, that's it.
For electrons which
have Coulomb charge,
where is the attraction?
And you wonderfully
described that there
is attraction between electrons.
It's like the couch effect.
If you sit on the couch,
you indent the couch,
and the person next to
you will move towards you.
Similarly, when an electron
goes through a lattice
it leaves a polarization
of the lattice behind
and the next electron is
attracted to this trajectory.
So what you are explaining is
the phonon-mediated process
which leads to attraction.
But if I have two fermions
which attract each other
I don't need this complication.
AUDIENCE: But couldn't
you even get it
without a lattice
[INAUDIBLE] the Fermi gas.
If I have one fermion,
and I move it,
the location that it was has
been-- All the other fermions
have been pushed away
from that so there's
a sort of a density
depletion there.
So couldn't the
other spin component
see that as
effective attraction?
PROFESSOR: Density
depletion are density waves,
and these are
sound waves-- maybe
there is a possibility to map
it on phonons in the lattice.
I haven't heard about it.
So I've never heard about
such an attraction which
would happen in a Fermi gas,
which would give the Coulomb
repulsion for some correlation
attractive component.
What is well-described,
of course,
is the couch model or the
phonon model you mentioned.
But I'm saying, this is just
giving you the attraction.
But the question
is now, and that's
the next expression
I raised, once we
have an attraction
between two particles,
do we need many-body physics
or single-particle physics
to have pairing?
So let me address that.
Now this is out of
the review paper,
you could be much more about it.
But it simply reminds you--
undergraduate problem--
what happens when you have
two particles with a very
weak attractive potential?
And, of course, since
you can eliminate
the center of mass motion,
when I say two particles
it's the same as one
particle attracted
to a central potential.
What you learn, or what could
may have already learned
in your undergraduate
days, is that in 1D,
if you have an infinitesimal
depths of the square of L,
you found a bound state.
The bound state will decay very
slowly, but it's a bound state.
In two-dimension you
also find a bound state.
In two dimensions
logarithm appears.
Often when logarithm appears
it's sort of the limit.
The logarithm is the
weakest form of binding.
And if you go one step
further, for a very small
attractive potential, you
do not have a bound state.
So in three -dimension
you need a minimum.
You need a critical
energy of the square
of L-- critical depths
before your bound state--
whereas, infinitesimal
attraction
is enough to bind particles
in one or two-dimension.
So therefore, when we
talk about fermions
with very weak attraction--
in 1D and 2D, no problem.
They can form pairs by that,
pairs even in vacuum. --
but, in 3D we need something
else because an infinitesimal
attraction is not
enough to form a pair.
Now let me ask you the
following question.
Let me just cover the slide
because it gives the solution-.
You all know that in
three dimension, when
you have radio symmetry,
you can transform
the three-dimensional
Schrodinger
equation into an
angular equation,
but then also into a
one-dimensional equation
for the radial wave function.
And of course, this
one-dimensional radial equation
has the same potential as the
original three-dimensional
equations.
So I don't know, I want
to hear from one of you.
Why does now an
infinitesimal square
of L potential with
attraction give bound states
in 1D, but not in 3D?
Because in 3D, the
radial wave equation
uses the same infinitesimal
potential as in 1D.
Jenny.
AUDIENCE:Because you have
to break down an effective
potential that takes into
account the centrifugal
PROFESSOR: Perfect, but
let's use L equals zero.
Then the centrifugal
correction is zero.
Otherwise you are right.
It's an effective potential.
But let's talk about L
equals zero, S states.
Then there is no correction
due to the centrifugal forces.
Colin.
AUDIENCE: Radial
derivative is no longer
just a simple second
derivative [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No it is.
You have a more complicated
radial derivative,
but then you go to
an equation which
just says D2DR squared
over function U
and it's exactly the
one-dimensional Schrodinger
equation, which you write down.
You can transform
the radial equation
with a more
complicated derivative
into something which is exactly
a 1D Schrodinger equation.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You can
[INAUDIBLE] relationship
between [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sure.
Uncertainty of relation
always can immediately
help you if you have
an uncertainty relation
for for kinetic
energy and you realize
that you don't have enough
potential, but maybe
mathematically, what
is different between
the identically-looking
1D Schrodering
equation and the
radial Schrodinger
equation for the
wave function U?
AUDIENCE: I don't know how
this is going to lead to it,
but I noticed one difference
is that in in the three
dimensional case you
can't go less than zero.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
In the three dimensional case
you have a wave function psi,
but then you do a substitution
that the 1D Schrodinger
equation is not for
psi, it is for U.
And U is the radial
part divided by R.
So you transform to a
different function, which
is one more power of R. And
the requirement because of this
is that your radial
wave function
of this one-dimensional
radial equation
has to have a node
in the center.
And now you see what happens.
If you start at zero, your
wave function shoots up.
If you don't have
enough attraction
it will never curve down and
become a normalizable state.
Whereas, in 1D you do
not have the requirement
that the wave function
if your 1D Schrodinger
equation has a node.
So you have the same equation,
the same infinitesimal
potential, but the
radial equation
has a different
boundary condition.
So that's the difference.
And that's important.
It changes the
physics completely.
OK.
Now it looks very different and
it seems you have to-- Niki.
AUDIENCE: What about 2D?
PROFESSOR: Limiting case,
we come to that in a second.
In 2D an infinitesimal
potential is still enough.
Now I want to show you how you
can take care of all dimensions
with one equation and not
solve three different equations
with three different
kinetic energy terms.
That goes as follows.
Recognize that this is just
Schrodinger's equation,
kinetic energy minus
energy equals potential.
But now we can
Fourier transform it.
And the nice thing about
Fourier transformation
is that the second derivative,
spatial derivative,
is simply q squared.
So therefore, if you describe
now everything in Fourier
space, you have q squared
plus k squared times psi,
but you divide by q
squared plus k squared.
Here you have a product.
The product turns
into convolution.
Anyway, it may be not the most
familiar way you've seen it,
but this is just Schrodinger's
equation in Fourier components.
And now we want to
simplify that we
have a short-range potential.
So we assume we have a
short range potential.
If you had a delta function,
the momentum components
of the potential would
be constant for all R.
But, we get into
something unphysical
if you don't put in a cutoff,
so we put in a cutoff.
But with that
cutoff, you can now
re-write the
equation as follows.
And now we want to do one thing.
We want to integrate over q.
Then on the right-hand side we
also have an integral over q.
And then we divide
by the common factor.
And what you get is this.
I know I'm going fast,
but this is nothing else
than re-writing Schrodinger's
equation for you.
But now look at it.
It has an integral
over all energies
with the density of
states, or of E, of energy.
E is k square.
This is the energy
of the bound state,
and we want the bound state.
And on the left
hand side we have
our infinitesimal potential.
And one thing is
clear, if you have
an infinitesimal
potential, we can only
get an infinitesimally
bound state.
So now we do the following.
If the left hand side
goes to 0, If you
go to an infinitesimal
attraction,
the left hand side diverges.
And the question is now,
if the energy goes to 0,
does the right hand
side diverge or not?
In other words,
if this integral,
where you said E equals
0, does not diverge,
you cannot fulfill this
equation with an infinitesimal
attraction in the
square of l potential.
So therefore, the
condition for bound state
is now that this expression
here with E equals 0, diverges.
And this combines
now all the cases.
And you have now an
integral equation,
and you can now solve
it for infinitesimal V0.
You can solve it, what is the
energy as a functional of V0?
And in two dimensions, when the
density of states versus energy
is constant, you have
the weakest divergence
on the right hand side.
It's logarithmic divergence.
In three dimensions,
this doesn't diverge.
In one dimension it
diverges big time.
Two dimensions is the limit.
There's a logarithmic
divergence.
And if you do the math,
which is elementary,
but I'm not doing it,
you find that the energy
of the bound state depends
exponentially on minus 1
over the attraction.
So for infinitesimal
attraction, this
turns to E to the
minus infinity.
It's the weakest bound
state you can imagine,
and this happens in 2D.
OK, let's go from one particle
physics back to fermions.
And let me now present to
you how Leon Cooper really
found the key ingredients to
the long standing problem, "How
do electrons pair in
a superconductor?"
And he did the following.
He made an artificial
simplification,
which you can see is ingenious.
He assumed the following.
He just wanted to understand,
how do two electrons pair?
But he simply assumed
that those two electrons
are on top of a Fermi sea.
So he pretty much said, "I
want to solve the problem where
two electrons just scatter
through all available states
and then figure out if an
infinitesimal attraction
between those electrons
leads to binding."
Of course, in the real world,
the electrons in the Fermi sea
are identical to
those electrons,
to those two special electrons,
and they're constantly
exchanged.
But he simply made
this artificial model.
And then, of course,
we can immediately
write down the
equivalent equation.
It's exactly the same
formalism, except for when
we integrate over
all energies here.
We integrate, yes.
We integrate over the
three-dimensional energy.
But now, we integrate
only over a small region
on top of the Fermi sea.
And everything looks the same.
We just have sometimes
subtract the Fermi energy.
All energies are now
measured not relative to 0,
but relative to
the Fermi energy.
If you compare it to the
equation I just showed you,
forcing the particle
bound state,
you pretty much see that
everything is the same,
except for energies are measured
relative to the Fermi energy.
And secondly, we're not
integrating from zero,
as before.
We start integrating
from the Fermi energy.
And that means now, that in
this area of integration,
the three-dimensional density
of states is constant,
namely it's the density for
where the energy is the Fermi
energy and can be pulled
out of the integral.
And then we have the same
logarithmic divergence
as we had in two dimensions.
So therefore, the problem
of two electrons scattering
on the surface of
the Fermi sea means
that we have essentially
the same condition
for the electrons as if they
would live in two dimensions.
Question.
If the world were
four-dimensional,
and we would have
the same physics,
we have two electrons on the
surface of the Fermi sea,
would the physics of the two
electrons, in that regard,
be 4 minus one dimension,
three dimension,
or would it be two dimensions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
exactly the question.
Let's assume you had
four spatial dimensions.
For this kind of analysis,
it's the effective density
of states on the Fermi surface.
Now, two dimensional?
Or is it three-dimensional?
AUDIENCE: It should
be three, right?
You remove one
dimension by restricting
yourself the area
in the Fermi sea?
PROFESSOR: It is, if you say
the particles have momentum
on the Fermi surface, if
the Fermi surface fixes
one momentum, and now they
have three different momenta.
So in that sense, the motion on
the surface in four dimension,
is three-dimensional.
But, it was sort of a trick
question, to some extent,
because here we have
reformulated everything
with energy.
And the answer is now, the
density of state is constant.
It is the four-dimensional
density of states,
but evaluated at
the Fermi energy.
So therefore, no matter
in what dimensions
you are, because you are
restricted to the Fermi sea,
you integrate over energy with
a constant density of states.
And if you pull the
constant density state out
of the integral you have
a logarithmic divergence.
And you pretty much
get the same answer.
So, therefore the
physics in four dimension
would be the same.
It would be the fermions
which live on this Fermi
surface would just
marginally pair.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
the reduction of dimensions?
Where does [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, the motion,
you can see on the Fermi surface
is n minus one dimension.
But the energetic
analysis always
uses a constant
density of state.
And the constant
density of state
is characteristic
for two dimensions.
So you have both.
If you analyze the
motion, yes, you
have n minus one dimensions.
But if you look at the
question of bound states,
you encounter the same
situation as in two dimension,
because the effective density
of states is constant.
OK so with that, the
message I have for you is,
Cooper pairing is a
single particle effect.
A single particle trapped to
an arbitrarily weak potentially
in two dimensions.
And the only many-body
physics which
allows those Cooper
pairs to form
is, that you have
a Pauli blocking,
that you have Fermi sea,
which prevents particles
from going into
the deep Fermi sea.
They stay on the surface,
and therefore, they
form weak pairs.
So the only many
body physics, which
we need for that kind of
pairing is Pauli blocking.
Mark.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Can you explain what is
ER in the previous slide?
PROFESSOR: ER was the cutoff.
We were cutting
off the potential
at a short-- we didn't
use a delta potential,
we used a square of l potential,
which extends out to R. And ER
is the recoil energy associated
with R. Its 1 over R squared,
with a few h bars and n to
give it the units of energy.
Colin.
AUDIENCE: If you
go back to that,
I can imagine Taylor
expanding my density of states
in any dimension
around Fermi energy.
I'll always have my constant
term, and the first term is 3D,
it's E to 1/2, or
some linear term.
Doesn't that imply that
even if give the system
any infinitesimal
amount of energy,
that integral no
longer diverges and--
PROFESSOR: No.
The question of
divergence is robust.
Depends only on the leading
term and not on the expansion.
If you have a
divergence you are not
changing it by a
small correction term.
Because a small correction
term is on top of unity.
If you start with the
density of states at 0,
which goes with
epsilon to some power,
you have a different situation.
You catch really the
physics by saying
you take a constant
density of states here.
Anyway, let me just go on and
say we should now figure out--
and this is also
important when it
comes to pairing-- which pairs
are the most important ones.
And the message I
want to give you here,
the pairs which are
most important one,
on the ones which
have zero momentum.
Because those pairs can scatter
to all states on the Fermi
surface without violating
momentum conservation.
However, if you have the total
momentum of the two particles
which is non-0, they
can only scatter
on the segment of the sphere.
And you got already the message
that the higher the density
of state, the better
it is for the binding.
So therefore, the pairs
which have the largest
binding energies will be the
one with total momentum zero.
OK, now we go from
Cooper to BCS.
Those three guys figured
out how they can now
take the physics
described by Cooper,
and really fold it into a
correct many-body formalism.
In other words, not to
artificially have 2 fermions,
which scatter, and there
is just the Fermi sea
of the other ones.
They are now treating
the two electrons,
which scatter, on equal footing
with the whole Fermi sea.
So, now we have democracy, all
electrons are created equal.
So I want to derive for
you the BCS wavefunction
in the way which was not the
way done by Bardeen, Cooper,
Schrieffer, but it makes
an immediate analogy
with Bose-Einstein condensation.
, So what happens is you
could now have the idea--
of course I'm very suggestive
in leading you to this idea--
two fermions form a pair.
And if the pairs both
condense, then each pair
would be identical.
So maybe we should
take our n particles,
our n fermions-- n half spin
up, n spin down-- each of them
should form a pair.
So one and two forms a pair,
three and four forms a pair,
and such.
And then we see,
our wavefunction
of identical fermion
pairs slash bosons is just
the product of those pairs.
But the pairing wavefunction,
the molecular wavefunction
if you want, so
[INAUDIBLE], it's
the same for all particles.
So this is just like in the
Bose-Einstein condensate.
We have a product state of n
times the same wavefunction.
Here we have a product
state of n over two
times the same
pairing wavefunction.
We should anti-symmetrize
that's important.
Now let us see what we got.
Well, we describe everything
in second quantization.
We use field operators
which create particles
at a certain
position, and then we
have the wavefunction
of the pairs
to make sure they are created
in the right position.
We transform everything
our operators
and do Fourier transform.
We go from operators
and positions space,
to operators in momentum space.
But now, it's just formalism.
You can read up about it..
But the important thing is
now I define a pair creation
operator.
This pair creation operator
creates one of those pairs.
And what it does is it creates.
We want to focus on the
pairs we zero momentum.
It forms a plain wave fermion
in the momentum state with minus
k, with opposite
spin with plus k.
So these are sort of two
opposite, plain waves
with zero momentum.
But now the leading factor
is the Fourier transform
of this pairing wavefunction.
So if you want to assume it's
a molecule or wavefunction,
Fourier transformers, and
this is the leading factor.
And with that definition, this
is now the creation operator
of a molecule consisting
of two fermions.
OK.
So now, we can say, well
maybe a good idea of what
describes our system
is now, so to speak,
a Bose-Einstein
condensate, where
we create n over two
pairs out of the vacuum.
Well, first I want to show
you that this is actually
the BCS wavefunction.
Most people do not to use this
form for the BCS wavefunction,
but I want to show you
mathematically identical
the BCS wavefunction.
But first I have to clarify is
that really a Bose-condensate?
If I would have shown you this
equation without telling you
anything about it, ya, this
looks -- n over 2 identical, b,
boson-- Bosonic particles.
But now we have to
be more careful.
We have our definition
for the pairing operator.
And now we can calculate.
Are those bosons?
Let's just look at
the communicator
between b dega, b dega, bb.
Yes fine fine.
But now, the commutator
between b and b dega is not 1.
It would be 1 if
the probability,
that the population of one
of those plain waves k,
is much, much
smaller than 1, then
the commutator is full filled.
But the population
of momentum states
depends on the size of the pair.
If the size is huge, you have
low lying momentum states,
which have a huge population.
If the size is small of
the pair, you can say,
in a tightly-bound system,
particles have so much
0 point energy that
every given momentum
state has pretty
much 0 occupation.
So in other words,
this criterion here,
tells us that our
pairs are bosons if nk
is much smaller than 1.
But if nk is not smaller
than 1, then those pairs
act out in a Fermionic way.
And the criterion
happens exactly when
the size of the pairs is
comparable to the particle
spacing.
So in other words,
what we have described
with this wavefunction
is, we have a wavefunction
which is a two
Bose-Einstein condensate
for tightly bound pairs.
That's what we expect.
It still has this form,
but those pairs now
feel the Fermi pressure.
And therefore, this
is automatically
taken account in the formalism.
Colin
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This one.
PROFESSOR:It's a commutator
not the anti-commutator.
It's bb dega minus b dega b.
I just want to be careful here
because, for fermions, you
often use the anti-commutator.
But I want to check
with these bosons,
so I use the Bosonic,
the commutator,
not the anti-commutator.
Let me just show you
one thing real quick.
Namely, that this wavefunction
is identical to the famous BCS
wavefunction.
Well, almost, not quite.
You know that this
is a state which
has n particles,
n over two pairs.
Remember when we
talked about photons,
we had Fock states with n
particles, with n photons.
But we also had coherent states,
where alpha square was n.
But this was sort of, the
classic coherent state.
And this coherent
state could be expanded
as a sum over Fock states.
And one can now
say, to some extent,
when it comes to certain
properties of light, n photons
sometimes it's
important to distinguish
whether it be a Fock
state or coherent state.
But, for many
things, if you have
n photons in the same
state, you can have a laser,
then you have a
coherent state, or you
have n photons in a cavity.
And that may be similar.
So let me show you what happens
when I take this Fock state,
but construct what is now
the coherent state version.
In the coherent state
version-- this here
is a Fock state
with j particles--
but now I take a
coherent superposition,
and I've chosen my
factors such that I
will get a coherent state.
And indeed, I get
the coherent state.
This is now sort of, what
the laser is for Fock state,
is this coherent state for a
state with a specific Fermion
number.
And this state now,
when I just-- you
can also say in many-body
physics-- we say,
I just went from the
canonical ensemble,
which has a fixed
number of atoms
to the grand canonical ensemb.e,
where the number of atoms
fluctuates.
But now I can simply
use the definitions.
If I Taylor expand
this component
because all higher powers of the
Fermionic creation [INAUDIBLE]
operators give 0.
The Taylor expansion ends
after the first term.
And with one more step, I have
the famous BCS wavefunction.
So therefore the
BCS wavefunction,
which has been widely used
to describe superconductors,
is really identical to
creating n over 2 pass b,
identical pass b, in the vacuum.
And I'm just telling you
that, because that means now,
mathematically, the BCS
wavefunction, which many people
say describe a very,
very different physics,
is formally equivalent
to the wavefunction
for Bose-Einstein condensate.
OK.
So what have you done so far?
We talked about one
particle physics,
how very weak attraction
leads to bound states.
We realized that if fermions
live on top of a Fermi sea,
it gives at least the binding,
the energetic consideration,
a two dimension character.
And we have two states.
And we have bound states for
infinitesimal attraction.
And now we have
used our intuition.
If those pairs exists, if they
form kind of a Bose-Einstein
condensate to construct
a trial wavefunction.
And now I want to take
this trial wavefunction
and show you how we can use
it to solve the Many-Body
Hamiltonian.
So far, single particle
physics, two particle physics,
intuition to get a
trial wavefunction,
but now we go to
many-body problem.
Colin.
AUDIENCE: Can you go
to the last slide?
So the BCS wavefunction has the
normal component and the parody
component.
Where does the normal
component come into the Bose--
PROFESSOR: This one?
Oh we are talking
here about t equals 0.
We are talking about
a wavefunction.
We are not talking
about finite temperature
where you have distribution
over excited states.
This is really
temperature physics.
Was that your question?
100% superfluid fraction.
OK, we are back
now. [? Timor. ?]
AUDIENCE: Just before
you get into this.
This maybe a silly
question, but why is it
that up has to pair with down.
It seems ok for up to
pair with up, right?
PROFESSOR: No.
What happens is, we
have assumed here
that we have
short-range interaction.
And up and up can never
come close together
because of poly
exclusion principal.
AUDIENCE: But then in
principal, if you have key wave
attraction, it could work.
PROFESSOR: You're talking
about now, different pairing
mechanisms.
I'm talking here about the plain
vanilla BCS s-wave pairing.
And that means spin
up and spin down pair.
Also, this is where
I can work out
the analogy with BEC-BCS
cross-over and such.
So I'm just giving you
the simplest example.
But yes, in helium-3
at high magnetic field,
you have one of the phases where
up and up pair for key waves.
It's a triplet, superfluid.
OK so we the Many-Body
Hamiltonian, and what
I want you to sort
of, enjoy now is,
I took you last class
through the bosons.
And you should maybe see how
the Fermions are different,
but we use similar concepts.
And so you may ask yourself
at the end of the day,
"Are the fermions really so
different from the bosons
when it comes to
super fluidity?"
But we're getting there.
Let's make the
same approximation,
we use the delta function here.
And we Fourier transform.
We go from position
space to momentum space.
But now comes one
important approximation.
Fermions are fairly complicated.
Look I mean, we have
products of four operators
and we integrate over three
momenta, Initial momenta,
and to the initial momentum,
the final momentum,
and the momentum transfer.
So we have an integral
over three momenta.
We have to do something,
this is too complicated.
And the BCS approximation
is, the only focus
in these sum of pair operators
that we scatter, or we have.
k prime minus k prime
scatters into k minus k.
So we pretty much
save whenever we have,
in the interaction
term, two fermions.
We are only looking
at pairs, where
the center of mass
momentum is 0.
You can say it's an
uncontrolled approximation,
but it's based on intuition.
So the hope is that
we still capture
the essence of super fluidity by
doing this major simplification
of the Hamiltonian.
So now I want to show you
that this Hamiltonian can
be solved in two ways.
And this really
connects me with things
you have learned previously.
One is, we can use as
a variational ansatz
these pair of wavefunctions
which I just constructed.
That's actually what Bardeen
Cooper Schrieffer did, but they
used, as a tidal wave
function, the BCS wavefunction
with the use and [? Weiss, ?]
which is identical.
But then I want to
show you, partially
because I'm feeling
nostalgic about the bosons,
that you can also use the
Bogoliubov transformation.
The same method we
learned for the bosons.
So variation on
this just means use
this BCS wavefunction,
which I just showed you,
plug it into the
Hamiltonian, and all
you do is, you vary the
coefficients u and v until you
find the minimum of the energy.
And this gives you the
famous BCS solution.
And this is the plain
vanilla formalism
for superconductors in
Fermionic super fluidity.
OK I don't have time
to go into details,
but I think you've
got the big picture.
But let me know just
emphasize the similarities
we had with the bosons.
We have a Hamiltonian, even
with the BCS approximations
that we got writ over 1,
sum over momenta by focusing
on the pairs with c
[INAUDIBLE] mass momentum.
You still have products
of four operators.
We want to get rid of it.
But now we use a
mean field idea.
We always get rid of
products of four operators
by grabbing one or two
of them, and saying,
"we don't look at
the operator, we
look at the expectation value,
which is the mean field."
So we want to make a
mean field approximation.
But when you go for
bosons more simply,
you just took the operators,
c zero, zero momentum,
and replacing with
the square root
of n 0, the number of
atoms in the condensate.
But now we have to be a
little bit more subtle.
So what we should now define,
is a pairing mean field.
Not an expectation value of
c 0, but an expectation value
of this creational annihilation
operators four pairs.
A little bit more abstract,
but it follows the same logic.
And then we do the
decoupling approximation,
which I lectured about to you
with a [? mod ?] insulator,
that whenever we have products
of operators, of products
of pair operators now,
we take the mean value,
but we neglect the product
of the fluctuations.
Exactly what I've shown you
before when we described
the [? mod ?] insulator
to superfluid transition.
OK.
This is the pairing
field with an index k
and eventually it's
important to define a delta.
The famous gap in the BCS,
with the BCS COE, which
is a sum over all
pairing fields with k.
And it is this delta which
plays the role of the condensate
wavefunction exactly
the same way as psi,
the macroscopic wavefunction
in the [? Kospiesky ?] equation
[INAUDIBLE].
So you do the same thing,
we just write it down,
we drop quadratic terms,
which are fluctuation terms.
And the moment we
have now, simply
bi-linear product of operators.
We do exactly the same
as we did with bosons,
we transform to a new
set of operators, which
is the Bogoliubov
Transformation.
Of course, this time,
we want to make sure
that those transforming
Fermionic operators,
we want to make sure that
after transformation we
fulfill Fermionic commutator.
And then we determine
coefficients
in such a way that
cross-terms cancel out,
and what we obtain now is
a diagonalized Hamiltonian.
It's diagonalized, it has
the ground state energy.
And this, you now
realize, this is
nothing like an
harmonic oscillator.
It's a quasi particle gas
of independent excitations.
Gamma k is an excitation
with energy E K,
and this means we've
diagonalized the problem.
I can't do justice
to the formalism.
I think the best I
can do here for you
is to show how the
same ideas come back
and solve the same problem.
Also everything is
now for fermions.
Mark.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Separate to [INAUDIBLE]
At the very top of the line,
you have [INAUDIBLE] then
the next slide,
you have the delta,
which is the sum over k
expectation [INAUDIBLE] sum.
PROFESSOR: I derived it
myself because it confused me.
But I can just reassure you.
If you take the
original Hamiltonian,
pluck this into
here, and neglect
the product of the
smaller fluctuations,
you get exactly this equation.
It's really just accounting
and regrouping terms.
There is no assumption,
no concept involved,
it's really just plugging it in.
The physics is that we
neglect the correlation
of the fluctuations.
OK.
Yeah, I think I want to
wrap up the fermions.
We still want to talk a
little bit about ions,
but we have now solved it.
Either with the a
variational [? onsets ?]
or with the Bogoliubov
Transformation.
Two very different ways
lead to the same solution.
We have quasi particles.
Here, we determined
what the energies are.
They are a little bit
complicated equations
to find what the
quasi-particle energies are.
But everything is known, we
can now throw in temperature.
Colin wanted final temperature.
Well what happens with this
Hamiltonian final temperature?
Well, we just have
occupation number
for those quasi-particles,
the thermal occupation,
and we have to self-consistency.
Now look what happens in the
presence of quasi particles.
This eventually
leads to an equation
for the critical temperature.
So what we see
here is a function
of the inverse
scattering lengths.
Here we have a BEC
temperature which is constant.
And when we go on the BCS
side, where we no longer form
bound molecules, we
have is exponentially
decaying temperature for
very small attraction.
The transition temperature to
the Superfund superfluid state
is exponentially small.
All this is theory, but it has
been experimentally observed.
If you want to pair fermions,
we just need two states.
At MIT we use mainly Lithium-6.
Lithium-6 has many
hyper find states,
but we just use
the two lowest one.
In a high magnetic field, where
we have a Feshbach resonance,
we pair the particles--
well we needed the lasers
and equipment-- and then we
observe pair condensates.
They look exactly like
atomic condensates,
but their pairs inside.
That they're really
pairs inside we
found out with a f spectroscopy.
And eventually when you locate
the gases we find vortices.
And you know already,
vortices are the smoking gun
of super fluidity.
So with that I've rushed you
through an important and very
elegant chapter of physics,
the BEC BCS cross-over.
Let me just sort of
end with an outlook
that I've talked about
basic phenomenon in bosons
and fermions, both centered
about super fluidity,
because I think it was
pedagogical to show
you the differences
and the similarities.
But we can now regard those
ultra-cold bosons and fermions
as building blocks of
quantum simulators,
building blocks to
understand, in its simplest
manifestation,
interesting physics.
So you can see, the Bosic
gases are quantum simulator
for superfluid helium.
The Fermi gases are a quantum
simulator for superconductors.
We briefly talked
about optical lattices,
which can be regarded
as a [? quantum ?]
simulator for
crystalline materials.
But there is much more you can
do with those building blocks.